welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with the second
trailer for peninsular now out there's a
lot to sink your teeth into the trying
to be sans sequel is getting a lot of
hype behind it and throughout this video
we're gonna be breaking down the new
trailer giving more thoughts on it and
discussing everything that you need to
know about the movie there may be some
spoilers here so if you want to go into
the film as blind as possible then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for updates on the film as we get them
and also drop a thumbs up if you enjoy
the video without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into our
breakdown of Peninsula okay so if you
missed our last breakdown on the movie
and just need a quick catch-up then the
next part of the video is for you the
title peninsula means a massive land
surrounded by water and career itself is
actually classified as one from this
it's a safe assumption to make that due
to the events of the first movie the
country has been completely quarantined
and no one is allowed in or out of it
the first film ended with a feeling that
the virus and all the survivors of the
outbreak were being stopped at the
border and thus we can take from this
that the country is completely in
lockdown and has been for the last four
years topic alright
as with most sequels though we're
scaling up so we're the first film took
place predominantly on a train judging
by the title and the nature of sequels
in general this movie will likely be
taking place across most of Korea it's
also being completely finished filming
wise so we will definitely be seeing its
release come the 30th of July now as for
the story when the trailer first dropped
it came with a plot synopsis that said
the following four years after the
events of train to Busan all of Korea
has been abandoned and all that's left
is its geography zombies and the ruins
of South Korea a group of Marines on a
retrieval mission get trapped inside and
start to witness something that will
test the
of the world initially we speculated
that this was going to perhaps be a
biological weapon or something far worse
however this trailer reveals that there
instead going back into the country in
order to retrieve a bag full of money
this has been left behind on a truck and
an American Gangster seemingly wants to
get it back and then split with the
group since the country destabilized
it's likely that many of the survivors
of the outbreak will left very poor and
you can probably guess that they're all
struggling to get by imagine a pandemic
for years and years where you can't
really get a stable job and people are
trying to eat you all the time no doubt
2.5 million would seem like something
that's worth risking your life for now
the first trailer did say in an
abandoned world and I had a couple of
people in the comments disagreeing with
me over this matter I said that I think
the word world was just referring to
Korea and the rest of it would be okay
and the opening of this teaser seems to
confirm that I can't see any reason why
they would want the money if the rest of
the planet was completely in ruins so we
can take from this mission that England
good old England still bloody fine and
dandy we are it also seems like the main
character jungkook escaped the outbreak
after seeing it firsthand the trailer
opens with him saying the words go back
in there so in order to go back in there
he has to have been there before and yet
Captain Obvious here surprised they
didn't ask me to do the job now if you
cast your mind back to the first film
you may remember that the zombies were
pretty useless in the dark and that they
weren't much of a threat if you could
keep the lights out I can imagine that
it was proposed that this would be an
easy job and that all the group would
have to do is be as quiet as possible
and get back before sunrise at one point
in the trailer a character also says
let's move out to sundown so it seems
like the characters are well aware that
it's easy to tackle Aziz when they're
having Z's get it sleep joke sleep joke
now though the zombies are useless in
the dark sound attracts them a lot and
clearly one of the characters setting
off a car alarm doesn't help them to
stay stealthy though they get the money
this noise is gonna bring a lot of
trouble away and thus some survivors
step in to save their lives
guessing this kind of puts them in debt
to them and they'll probably want a way
out as I can imagine living in Korea
during these times it's probably worse
than this YouTube channel
anyway it's a great rescue scene I love
how there's flesh shot into the air to
bring the forces of the undead away as
the light is something that they're
attracted to so it seems like they set
out to aid each other and the rest of
the trailer centers around them tackling
the zombies in different scenarios this
eventually leads to them coming face to
face with the villains of the piece that
seemed to be rounding up humans and
making them fight against the undead and
all that's break down we stated that it
look like this scene was taking place in
a prison and that this may have been a
group of criminals that were left in
their cells whilst the gods and rest of
the population fled the prisoners were
running the prison and in the first
trailer to me at least it added an
escape from new york aesthetic to the
film however looking at it here and
getting a couple more close-ups i think
it might actually be set in a shopping
mall
there are a pair of escalators which i
don't think that they would really have
in a prison and this location could be a
slight nod to Dawn of the Dead those
captured by the group are forced to
fight in gladiator arenas but looks like
they managed to escape and make another
run for the border in a Jeep clearly
they're tracked by the villains and I
love the mad max-style chase scene that
seems to be happening towards the end of
the film again this could be another
reference to Escape from New York and
overall it looks like it's gonna be an
amazing climax in which they have to ram
into hordes of zombies while it's also
keeping the people that want them dead
off their back they're also having to
outrun the Sun and yeah just a lot of
things going on in the finale by the
looks of it now a couple of
miscellaneous things that you may have
noticed that I do think need to be
touched upon there's a remote-control
car that is used to distract zombies and
also a Gatling gun that fires flares
clearly these are both being chosen for
their bright lights and will be used to
draw the zombies away from the humans I
think I pretty much got everything in
this trailer but yeah let me know if you
know is something that I missed if you
watch my first breakdown then you'll
know that I thought the movie looked a
bit cliched which was a shame because
the first film was so unique however
seeing it here it's almost like a heist
movie set during a zombie apocalypse and
that definitely makes me more excited
the first film and keyboard Ian's
members engaged because it kept
switching up the locations whilst
keeping things central to the Train here
though it seems like they're going above
and beyond that and keeping the group
constantly moving I think it's fitting
that it looks like it's gonna end in a
big chase as the speed of the train
towards the end of the prior entry and
the running that went on in the last
half hour really kept your blood pumping
overall this looks like an immense movie
I do trust James Wan to deliver
something that audiences love it's
really become a big name in horror over
the last decade or so and everything he
touches seems to do well so I do have a
lot of faith in the movie while I was
initially only slightly interested in
the film this trailer has got me all
aboard the movie and I can't wait to see
if this ride is just the ticket sorry
some crap train puns there now there
have been a lot of theories that this is
going to tie in with Kingdom on Netflix
a Korean zombie show set centuries ago
the rumors are that the disease in that
is also linked to the one in this but as
of now we don't really have any
information on whether this is true or
not though the creative team behind the
two aren't linked I think in my head I
will forever think of them being part
the same universe but sadly as of now we
have no official confirmation on whether
this is the case or not I really hope
there's some Easter eggs in the movie
that kind of hint towards that but yeah
as of now we have no idea but but let's
keep hoping that they link them somehow
I mean there's zombies they're the same
please do it go on one please
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the trailer and if you're as
hyped for the movie as I am I think it's
going to be one of the big releases of
the air and let's be honest it doesn't
really have much to compete against now
make sure you comment below and let me
know and if you enjoy this video and
want something else to watch it that
makes you check out a breakdown of one
of the worst movies of all time 365 days
which is going to be linked at the end
you want to support the channel from as
little as 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below
we massively appreciate you and as a
thank you you access to content early
we're gonna come chat to us after the
show either follows that heavy spoilers
or click the disc or link in the
description below every month we give
away free movies to people are
subscribed to the channel and this month
you kill when the MCU infinitely saga
box set and all you have to do is
comment on a video and make sure you
subscribe with notifications on the more
videos you comment on the more you
chance of winning so make sure you get
involved but when it's gonna be chosen
at random on the 15th of July and the
cell be shipped out from them to ever
gets the prize it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe huge thank you
for taking the time to watch this I've
been definition you've been the best now
see you next time take care
[Music]